this man matt gourley is going to be a
father in just a few days for the first
time um and you've just gone through
this experience what do you have to tell
him i just i don't know i think the most
important thing tac does is make sure
there's always food in the house okay uh
just make sure that that people know
tack is your house is my husband you
can't just say tack and people know oh
right that's a real name yeah it's a
very strange name what strange name
no it is kind of it is a little strange
first time you ever told me about him
you when i met this guy i really like
his name's tack like tack on the board
or tic-tac-toe that's what you said yeah
and went well okay if you have to
explain that name boy i just realized
about what my first name was
they know really yeah
that's
shortened name his real name is artak
our our talk our talk yeah
anyway yeah
anyway uh
uh i do i have i don't know i mean do i
i think that you just do whatever amanda
says
okay i'm i mean i'm sort of planning on
that yeah that just happens anyway i
know my wife just took charge and uh she
spoke with the ferocity and uh
commanding power of zeus
there was no questioning what was gonna
happen so um and i think i don't know
that must be evolution taking over you
know i don't know what happened but
suddenly i remember feeling like oh i am
no longer in charge and i have not been
in charge since i don't think i was in
charge before you had children but yeah
certainly not afterwards yeah yeah were
you there in the delivery room i'm
presuming right yes yes and how do you
have any advice for me in that sense uh
i had a very aggressive we had a very
aggressive doctor who really believed
that the husband should uh participate
fully and um and and i just thought
that's what everyone did so i very much
did i mean i helped i mean
catch my my uh my daughter and cut the
cord and then uh same thing with my son
and so but i'm not sure everybody does
that i grew up watching reruns of i love
lucy and shows like that and they always
they were shot in black and white and uh
men in this situation wore baggy suits
and they paced around a well-appointed
dress waiting room yeah and then pastor
we're told there was a baby passed
around cigars and all went out to a
nightclub together he didn't even look
at the baby
wait that's not what's happening that's
not what's gonna happen
and so now we're in this world where i
felt like i had done seven years after
after my daughter nev was born uh i i
felt like i had been through medical
school oh yeah i i really just was like
and i was thinking that business of me
wearing a baggy linen suit and heading
out to the stork club with fred mertz
and having high balls and everybody
toasting me and then dancing the night
away to a latin band what happened to
that idea yeah but no that's not what
happens i had a c-section and tax said
the same thing he's like i should have
never looked on the other side of that
sheet and he does this thing where he
like it looks like you know the
demogorgon from uh stranger things oh
yeah
the way he describes it makes me feel
like that's what my body looked like oh
wow yeah very erotic
i don't know that she was trying to be
erotic it's just
i'm just i mean i don't want to speak
for you so i was trying to be erotic who
am i to know i apologize
it's very
alluring say it again please
very sensual it's a very sensual time
when you're getting a c-section
who feels like some internal organs um
oh that's curtain thing that you're
talking about which you know i i believe
is only present during a c-section and
not vaginal birth yeah no i had uh
my wife did not have a c-section but i
had an old vaudevillian puppet show
curtain brought in that's what i keep
saying too am i going to be backstage or
in the in the audience for that the baby
came out
the little curtain parted and i had a
little band of puppets playing
and then i had a little hat ready for my
daughter just as she came out and i went
[Music]
i was arrested by the way for doing all
that yeah the hospital shut that [ __ ]
down right away good that's good i do
want to take a second to thank you both
for this advice seriously it's been
so helpful
this
is
i feel like i've learned more than my
three birthing classes that i managed
i'm going to try and be sincere for a
second and i think i can do this you can
do it uh all right here's what i'm going
to tell you people are going to give you
all kinds of advice
and they're going to try to prepare you
and i am of the belief there is no
preparing anybody it's such a profound
change in your life everything goes from
black and white to color everything goes
from one dimension to nine dimensions
it's such a big change
block out everybody telling you
everything just go through this and
nothing anybody says is going to mean
anything to you
but it is going to be the best thing you
ever do in your life it's it's
absolutely transformative and great and
you're going to be a great dad so
i think you should just go through it
don't listen to anybody that now if if i
can be serious for a second that's truly
the best advice i've heard because
i i don't know how to articulate that's
something i've been wanting to hear
because you do get a lot of advice from
people yeah
i i feel like in my gut that sounds
right to me and i appreciate hearing
that yeah no i'm serious i'm absolutely
serious uh the only thing i tell anybody
and this is not something you need to
know now is
lots of video lots of pictures because
you will never
ever think i have too much video
of these guys
you know because my wife and i just
still go back and i'm so grateful we
just
you know and now with you know
iphones
that's right maybe speaking of erotic i
love that i said i'm going to be sincere
for a moment i'm just gonna work in plug
for apple also does that is that how it
works you just say iphone and you get a
free iphone iphone iphone iphone nice
try sona oh i don't know what the
difference is between you and me me
neither but anyway
ferrari my point is uh corvette 1911
taft stamp
i know that stamp
um take tons of video but i think all
other advice is foolish you will know
what to do yeah
until you don't and then you'll figure
it out
thank you thank you guys i will miss you
it's only a month i won't be gone long
but i will miss you guys i will miss you
so much you don't even understand
i have missed you i'm seeing on a piece
of paper here let me read this i will
miss you too
yes this was written out
by somebody
parentheses show human emotion i believe
there's more there's another line about
arrays
yeah oh here it is yes
and given the fact that you're both
uh raising families now i feel it
appropriate
that you be given a raise
yeah and it's a raise like no one has
ever seen before it is a raise like no
one's ever seen before
it's so small that it actually puts you
it can't be seen in a much higher tax
bracket without giving you
any real increase in your income
[Music]
that's nice well oh
you guys yep good luck to you have fun
give all our love
to uh the lovely amanda and uh go with
grace go with god oh yeah what you think
i have nothing else to say
i just felt like i wanted something that
sounded a little bit like i was talking
to an astronaut who was going into a
capsule okay and so that's go with grace
go with god is what i had yeah
okay
secure your fireproof
suit oh boy this is not going wrong this
is a mess it's so good to be back we're
back goodbye goodbye